if you're trying to do business with a  lot of local businesses within a 40-mile  radius you're going to get a lot more  people interested in talking to you if  you're asking them to come on your show  and talk about their journey of building  a business then you're going to get to  do a sales call and get them to hire you  if you record that properly and fully  understand how to chop up those pieces  of content and use them as a day in and  day out piece of content for your  LinkedIn profile for you and your  business and you add to that video three  to four sentences of context that maybe  the video didn't fully hit on that shows  the world you know what you're talking  about and you come from the lens of that  content not being a sales call but being  a source of information you will be  downright shot on the actual impact on  your business